gilles casanova consultant en stratégie
et communication
bonjour à venger le casanova merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors ces rumeurs d'un
remaniement ministériel ce qu'elles sont
crédibles selon les présidents peu remet
à lui et quand il veut il remanie à sa
main la question qui est posée c'est
l'ampleur politique parce que les noms
cités
stéphane le foll nous sommes dans un
ferme soutien du président manuel valls
nous sommes dans un homme face à un
homme de première ligne de soutien du
président les autres noms qui ont été
évoqués sont des noms extrêmement proche
du président alors c'est une ouverture
vers l'intérieur de la macro ni c'est
effectivement intéressant mais on
devrait noter que ces derniers jours le
président semble avoir été grisé par des
audiences télévisuelles autour de
prestations très théâtral et et il perd
un petit peu le contact avec le réel
ainsi il dit le lundi soir que l'on va
annuler la dette des pays d'afrique et
il dit hier que l'on va l'a confirmé au
contraire en permettant à ces pays de la
payer parce qu'on va retarder un petit
peu le paiement des intérêts donc on l'a
maintenant en face de la diffusion par
les autorités l'information qui vont
dans un sens et dans l'autre d'une
manière très difficile à suivre
et puis il ya des erreurs qui sont
pointés aussi dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire par ce gouvernement
pointé dans au sein même de l'opposition
on pense évidemment au 11 mai avec le
début éventuelle d'un déconfinement
progressiste notamment avec un retour
pour les écoliers sur les bancs de
l'école
est ce que finalement emmanuel macron il
peut chercher des boucs émissaires
écoutez la situation dans laquelle on
est est assez curieuse parce que ils
annoncent sans annoncer il évoque la
date du 11 mai puis il dit
c'est un début aussitôt le lendemain son
ministre de la
derrière et son ministre de l'éducation
indique que c'est un objectif que c'est
quelque chose qu'on souhaite et si vous
avez écouté avec attention les 27
minutes
j'en suis certain vous l'avez fait vous
n'avez pas entendu la doctrine française
sur le corps d'un virus quel est
l'objectif qu'est ce qu'on attend
est-ce qu'on a une doctrine comme madame
merkel lundi que c'est à dire qu'en 60 %
de la population a été infectée et à
développer les anticorps l'épidémie
s'arrête et il faut essayer d'avoir le
plus tôt possible un vaccin un
traitement et isoler les personnes en
danger mais tu ne pas arrêter de vivre
les anglais et les néerlandais ont cette
même politique
on ne sait pas si c'est celle qui est
choisi par emmanuel macron on sait qu'il
est allé rencontrer le professeur abou
été que celui fille hier dans une
intervention sur twitter a expliqué que
l'épidémie était terminée et que
vraisemblablement d'ici quelques
semaines il n'y aurait plus un seul cas
parce que les printemps arrête ces
épidémies pour des raisons qu'on ne
comprend pas toujours explique-t-il lui
même donc on ne sait pas donc comme on
ne sait pas c'est très difficile de
juger si effectivement il s'agit de la
tente que le printemps arrête l'épidémie
après tout le professeur round à une
certaine notoriété et notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux peut-être cela
arrivera-t-il peut-être cela n'arrivera
t-il pas on peut penser à ce qu'on voit
dans le reste du monde qu'il est peu
probable que cela arrive
alors quelle est la stratégie eh bien
nous ne la connaissons pas pour revenir
sur le fond de la rumeur gel casanova ne
parle d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale
cela suppose une ouverture à
main tendue vers l'opposition vous avez
eu l'air tout à l'heure de sous-entendre
que ce n'était pas vraiment le cas
ça veut dire quoi concrètement
concrètement les noms qui sont évoqués
sont des noms de stricte obédience macro
nist donc je ne vois pas là la moindre
ouverture
maintenant s'ils vont mal on sait que
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen sont
prêts à entrer au gouvernement là je
vous dis c'est autre chose
mais même d'autres noms qui serait moins
loin du président pour l'instant on ne
pressent pas un seul nom qui ne soit pas
directement dans l'orbité du président
et auquel le président n'aurait pas eu
l'occasion jusqu'ici de donner une
occasion d'avoir une responsabilité
ministérielle et vous pensez que que
l'exécutif justement sera prêt à rendre
des comptes de façon transparente
une fois que cette crise sera passée
même si on en est loin
il y a maintenant quelques semaines
l'exécutif s'est préoccupée d'une
question qui lui semblait tout à fait
importante présenter des projets de loi
pour qu'on puisse plus de destituer le
président de la république et pour que
les ministres puissent bénéficier d'une
immunité dans leurs activités politiques
en tant que ministre donc c'est
peut-être une réponse à votre question
merci beaucoup gély casanova pour avoir
répondu en direct à la question je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
stratégie et communication